welcome back this is the ben shapiro
chart number eight five five two three
six thirty to twenty eight eight five
five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight Jessica in Long Island you're on
the bench pure shot go for Jessica yes
yes I'm here hi how you doing I just
wanted to know I've been watching the
protests on TV and the majority people I
see are white how do you feel about them
chanting black lives matter
so I mean first of all let me just say
that the the phrase black lives matter
should be relatively uncontroversial
because again it is true that black
lives matter and I think everybody
agrees the black lives matter it's the
implication of the phrase that people
are objecting to the implication being
that they're a bunch of people who think
they don't write the I didn't you
generally don't Chan son controversial
things right people don't go out in the
streets and chants the sky is blue right
people don't go out on the streets in
and chants we love children rather you
like you don't chant uncontroversial
things when you when you chant black
lives matters the implication is that
they're a bunch of people who don't
believe the black lives matters and
that's what people are objecting to
that's why people will say all lives
matter
not because they are saying that black
lives matter less but because they're
saying right we agree that black lives
matter just as every other life matters
so you know I think that the implication
of the black lives matter movement which
is more than just the slogan the the
slogan itself fine
but again the implication is that black
people are under existential threat in
the United States and there's a vast
group of people in the United States who
don't care if black people are under
under existential threat that whole
implication is what people object to if
it were just you know an obvious if you
were just an obvious truism that black
lives matter I don't think it would even
be controversial people are chanting it
the bigger problem I'm seeing with a lot
of the white protestors is the the
attempt to expiate racial guilt by
people who have never done anything
wrong so you're seeing videos for
example there's a video going around of
this group of people in Bethesda
Maryland giant group of mostly elderly
white people it looks like who are
kneeling on the ground with their hands
up and taking a vow to spread the gospel
of anti racism among their colleagues
and like this is just absurd like your
did they do anything racist have they
been Pro racist the implication so much
of the media is built on the implication
that if you are not doing this
performative thing today then this is
because you don't care about black lives
so if you won't say black
matter today because you were busy or
because you think it's perfectly obvious
the black lives matter and I don't tend
to say perfectly obvious things as a
matter of course then that means that
you don't think black lives matter so if
I don't spend my day saying rape is bad
that must mean I think rape is good I
mean that that's an it's an absurd
contention but what the sort of
performative woke virtue signaling from
from white people who are taking on sins
that were not theirs so as to take the
sins on among a broader group of people
who are not then meaning when you see a
performative white woke liberal doing me
I'm taking on the sins of my ancestors
what they're really saying is I am NOT
taking on the sins of my ancestors all
the other white people who don't agree
with me are taking on the sins of the
ancestors right that's what they
actually mean and that's what that's
what's objectionable I think all right
okay thank you
you bet so all righty Ilan you're on Ben
you're on the bench be Rochelle go 41 hi
then I'm a legal gun owner in Canada and
on May 1st our government Institute of
firearms ban on a dozen different
firearms and bus 1500 variants or so
following a shooting that took place
here in Nova Scotia even though the
shooting itself to do the weapons that
are part of the span the government used
their authority to outright ban the sale
transportation and use of these weapons
without an indication of a buyback grant
funding system and sort and I actually
own one of these kind of weapon you're
aware that here we don't have the same
rights afforded to us like in the Second
Amendment and gun ownership it's
strictly a privilege but I'm hoping that
you can show the light I don't want
someone like me who wants to remain a
legal gun owner should do in this
situation I mean I've been around done
since people in my military service and
I don't really know what I should do in
this situation feels very unfair so I
mean the the because I don't know
Canadian law I'm a little hesitant to
speak is what you can do within the
bounds of Canadian law what what I will
say is that you know it's two very
different questions as to the moral
right and the legal right so obviously
someone's breaking into your house and
you use one of these illegal firearms to
defend yourself I do wonder if Canadian
prosecutors would actually prosecute you
on the basis of the gun ownership there
are lots of cases like that in the
United States where somebody has
violated some sort of minor gun law
because they have a magazine that was
illegal but they were defending their
business and they shot a bad guy and the
and the cops kind of got well and no
jury's gonna go along with that one
but with that said if you have a bunch
of different types of guns you know the
one that is illegal if you don't wanna
get prosecuted you don't use that one
and that this is the problem with living
in a liberal country that then by
liberal I do not mean free living in a
left-wing country that believes that gun
ownership is not a right better
privilege
so on your point actually in Canada you
aren't allowed to use guns to protect
your property there's no like the sense
of property ability with the left and
the Bene sword on the gun and people
have been accosted on that basis before
I think it's a that's only insane
obviously when we have something similar
in Los Angeles that you're like I'm not
clear on whether in LA if somebody
breaks into your store and you shoot
them whether you're allowed to actually
do that that's not clear I know that in
a lot of other states it is perfectly
clear but let's say a person breaks into
your store and they don't actually
display a gun and you shoot them I'm not
sure what the what the story is there so
you know these bad laws make for bad
situations that is for damn sure Elon
really appreciate the call Andy in San
Antonio Texas you're on the bench Pio
shall go forth go for dandy hey Ben hope
the weather's fini well in LA quick
question with a bit of a quick
background for you to make it a super
fast
so my question deals with some history
I'm a latter-day Saint Mormon and we
kind of had some history in the u.s.
with some persecution mobs you know
killing our leaders burning down houses
during the Progressive Era and
reconstruction missionaries were were
lynched in the south and Reed Smith was
the the first LDS senator to be locked
to the Senate he actually had a big
hearing in the early 1900's and wasn't
able to take a seat really for four
years but the hearing actually said he
was unfit based on his faith in
connecting to the church and I was just
thinking based on that that history it
kind of meets all the qualifications for
the the protected leftist groups I I
don't feel like a victim I don't know
anyone in my community that really feels
like a victim but my question is how
come
given given kind of like the history
it's kind of like one of those poster
child persecution in America stories how
come it's something like the Book of
Mormon musicals okay today in the same
that no like a claw musical never be
okay how do you know that that's right I
mean the answer is that for the left
being a part of a victim group does not
mean part of a group that has been
historically victimized it means part of
a group that is experiencing outcomes
that are they're not equal to the
outcomes of other groups right that's
what it means it doesn't mean that your
group has been historically victimized
it doesn't mean the other group has gone
through your ancestors went through
something tough it doesn't have any
relation to history it has solely and
completely to do with whether your group
is considered economically or societally
underperforming in some way versus the
broader average right that's literally
what it is
so Mormons are disproportionately
high-income Mormons are
disproportionately well-educated Mormons
typically live in two-parent households
and therefore they are not a victim
group right it doesn't matter that the
history of Mormonism is replete with a
fair bit of victimization right that
doesn't matter at all in the same way
Jews are not a victim group in the
United States does not matter the Jews
are actually the number one target of
hate crimes in the United States by all
available statistics and with a bullet
by like a huge margin that doesn't
matter Jews are disproportionately well
educated Jews are disproportionately
high income Jews are disproportionately
part of solid family structures and
therefore Jews are not a victim group
Asians in America are no longer part of
the victim group does not matter that
Chinese American workers were brought
here and basically treated slave labor
at the end of the 19th century in the
early 20th century doesn't matter the
japanese-americans were interned by the
hundreds of thousands during World War
two you are not a part of a victim group
because Asian Americans are
disproportionately high income Asian
Americans are disproportionately
well-educated so to be part of a victim
group means that you don't have to show
a history of you actually being
victimized right that is that is I would
say necessary but not sufficient you
have to show that you are currently not
experiencing the same outcomes as other
groups that your your outcome is is not
good and therefore because your outcome
is not good we can implicate Americans
history America's history of racism
sexism and bigotry which is why you
never see the left talking about America
is historically racist sexist bigoted
homophobic with regard to groups that
are that are disproportionately doing
well because that would give the lie to
the idea that America is cracking down
on the basis of group identity right
it's one of the reasons why people
object on the left to
saying well you know Asians have done
really well Latinos have an enormous
amounts of income ability they're
actually picking up on whites in terms
of income ability they never say that
Asians have actually outperformed whites
in terms of both income mobility as well
as wealth of ownership and educational
performance they that because that
wouldn't that would suggest that maybe
freedom exists in the United States
instead because the implication is that
all inequality is inequity they have to
first identify the they don't have to
identify the inequity they have to
identify the inequality it's not that
all inequity is in an inequality it's
that all inequality is inequity so first
you identify an area where a group is
not equal in outcome with another group
and then you just implicate inequity
then you say this is because of
unfairness you don't actually have to
identify the unfairness you just have to
identify the unequal outcome that that
is that that's the reason why Mormons
are not considered a minority group
victimized minority group in the United
States Andy cool well thanks for tunning
have a good one I appreciate the call
Ryan in Buffalo you're on the bench pure
Chicago for Ryan hi big fan I assumed
you post a lot about demonstrators
escalating the George Floyd protests
almost as if to blend the rioters and
the peaceful protesters together but in
my personal experience from what I've
seen live streams and being there are
many instances of police escalating
situations an elderly man pushed on I'm
sure you've seen a lot of footage my
question is shouldn't the trained
professionals be held at a higher
standard than the angry teenagers well I
mean the standard for violation of law
is the same for both meaning that if you
are a police officer and you engage in
extra legal behavior you should be
prosecuted for that or fired for it if
you are talking about a police officer
is under attack and the police officer
officer responds to the attack that of
course is not the same thing I think it
should be held to the same standard I'm
not sure why a police officer should be
held to a quote/unquote higher standard
than a teenager violation of laws
violation of law you'd have to give me
an example where a police officer does
something and it's he nature does
something and the police officer should
be held to a higher standard I mean
presumably police officers generally are
held to a higher standard in the sense
that they're not willy-nilly like it
like you've seen it repeatedly police
officers are being assaulted
bricks and bottles they're not running
into crowds just rapping people on the
head but by the same token you know to
try and presume that police officers are
supposed to just take that sort of stuff
endlessly the police officers are
automatons that you can sit you know
you're singing an NYPD Cruiser and
somebody's throwing Molotov cocktails at
the cruiser and you move forward ten
feet that you are now bad and evil
whereas if you were just a normal person
and somebody did that to you like police
officers are human beings as well and
treating them as non-human beings is a
pretty good way to to make sure that you
never have anybody signing up for a
police force ever again
agreed agreed I mean a really yeah
nobody wants to see and and as I said
like if you don't want to see bad
incidents with police on a raw level I
mean I said this today on a raw level if
you have more confrontations with police
on a raw level you will have more
absolute instances of the police doing
bad things right just because if you
let's say that you are over at a family
member's house and you and your family
member don't get along well one of the
ways that you usually don't have
conflicts with the family members not to
be at their house well if you go over to
their house there's gonna be more raw
instances of you guys not getting along
well if protesters get violent with
police officers there will be more
instances of police officers getting
violent with protesters and also if
there are just more instances of
protesters and police coming into
conflict broadly that's going to expose
more instances of cops acting badly
because you you just have a bigger
sample size to sample from medicine mean
the cops should be punished for that
sort of stuff if they do that sort of
stuff and I've seen some tapes of cops
doing stuff that I think is
inappropriate I think most of us have
seen those tapes at this point but yet
end that the rioters and looters and the
police are acting in similar ways during
this during this period is just
absurdity and again one of the things
that we are going to have to keep in
mind is that the police officers who are
out there putting their life and limb in
danger in order to prevent civilization
from falling into the cast that we've
seen over the last week we're gonna need
them and and the amount of time that
we're spending ripping police officers
who go about their daily work doing
really unrewarding things on behalf of
the safety of citizens largely in high
crime communities and largely in
minority communities you you will get a
Ferguson effect you mean Heather
McDonald has talked about this the idea
that cops are just gonna say listen I'm
not put I'm not gonna join the police
force I'm gonna take early retirement
I'm not gonna go into a dangerous area
if I hear about a petty crime I'm not
gonna go there because what happens if
it escalates and then I get dragged in
the jury there are some negative
ramifications to treating cops more
strictly than you would treat a civilian
I definitely you know and I think I've
seen a little bit more posting about the
the rioters as opposed to the the police
which was wise of my question was I feel
like more people are talking yeah I get
it but I'm not stuck in my house and
you're not stuck in your house today
because of the cops the reason you can
normally go out of your house is because
of the cops the reason you're stuck in
your house today or or last night
wherever you are if you worker feud was
because there are people who are running
around and committing acts of violence
and looting and arson that that would be
the big problem right now not the police
officers trying to stop all of that and
that is not to deny the presence of
police brutality or individual cases of
police racism appreciate the call we're
gonna take more of your calls at eight
five five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight that is eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show